hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
so the trolley problem you know i swear
that just a few years ago the trolley
problem was not of widespread
familiarity with people when i wrote the
big picture i explained the trolley
problem and i thought that you know some
experts knew about it but it wasn't a
widespread cultural phenomenon which it
appears to be today maybe because of the
good place that tv show but i'm not sure
anyway you know probably by now the
basic setup right you have a choice
between letting a trolley kill five
people by running away on the tracks or
by doing something
saving the five people but one other
person dies because of what you did and
there's different versions of the
trolley problem where what you do is
just flip a switch and then one person
dies on the tracks or you actually have
to shove somebody in front of the train
and when you do
psychological quizzes and you ask people
about this they will give different
answers on what the right thing to do is
depending on the specific action that is
called for even if the outcomes are the
same which is very interesting so the
point of the trolley problem which was
first proposed by philosopher philip a
foote and then dubbed the trolley
problem by judith jarvis thompson is to
heighten our clarity about the
competition
between two different ways of moral
reasoning there's roughly speaking a
deontological way deontological morality
is based on rules certain things are
right certain things are wrong so
killing someone is wrong right that's a
deontological maxim right there
versus a sort of consequentialist
version of morality that it's not about
the rules it's about the outcomes of
your actions whatever they may be and
again very roughly speaking deontology
would warn you against
making one of those actions that
switches the trolley from doing one
thing to another whereas
consequentialism would say save the most
people whatever that would be
so what's interesting is we all have
both of these intuitions and they do
compete against each other so one
question you can ask is forget about
what the right answer is the trolley
problem is never about saying what the
right answer is it's about how we reason
morally and therefore you can ask what
about what is literally going on in our
brains and that is a question that has
been tackled by today's guest joshua
greene and his collaborators and his lab
josh is a psychologist neuroscientist
and philosopher and he is interested in
this sort of deontology versus
consequentialism debate but also
interested in what is happening in our
brain when we are thinking
deontologically versus when we were
thinking consequentially and it's
different parts of the brain that sort
of light up
and when you get into this it's just
intrinsically interesting but then it
has enormous consequences for
further questions not just about
individual personal morality but about
tribal cooperation or competition what
josh calls global metamorality and so
forth so there's a fascinating
conversation and there's a there's a
bonus that is coming here uh josh
thought about what he was doing and
realized there were implications for
charitable giving you know he's one of
these people uh there are many including
myself who think that there are more and
less effective charities to give to but
then there are also charities that tug
on our heartstrings directly so he
helped found a program called giving
multiplier giving multiplier will let
you have it both ways they will let you
both give to the charity that really is
personal and important to you while also
spreading some wealth to those effective
altruist kind of charities that just
have a huge impact as far as the
consequences are concerned and here's
the bonus
mindscape listeners get a special
benefit here so they've set up
joshua and his friends have set up a
special code if you go to
givingmultiplier.org
mindscape
they will match your donations to a
higher rate than usual so this is a good
thing to do no matter what but as a
mindscape listener you get to do just a
little bit more good for the world than
usual so that's a nice thing i like to
think
that listening to mindscape helps do a
little bit of good for the world because
it helps us think about how the world
works and make it a better place but
here you can put a cash value on those
ideas by giving to the right place
that's an exciting little thing so with
that let's go
[Music]
joshua green welcome to the mindscape
podcast
great to be here thanks
i thought that we would
start the conversation by sort of
setting out our philosophical um
convictions on the table here we'll get
more empirical later on but uh you know
a lot of your empirical work seems to be
driven by interest in philosophical
questions so
when it comes to morality and for that
matter uh uh meta ethics why we choose
uh our ethical systems what are your
convictions where do you come down on
utilitarianism deontology virtue ethics
all those big questions
right so um
i'll start with in a
honoring you i'll start in a big picture
kind of way
um i i think of morality first and
foremost as a natural phenomenon so i
don't think of morality as something
that descends from on high uh from
outside the observable universe in a
theological way or in some other way and
not only that i don't i think of
morality as something that comes up from
below so a a useful contrast here is
with mathematics where it is plausible
to think that uh
basic mathematical truths or complex
mathematical truths in some way are
completely independent of human minds
that two plus two would equal four
regardless of of whether or not any
humans ever existed certain basic facts
about the the the nature of entities and
their relations to each other
those things just are that way and
humans may accurately or inaccurately
perceive them when it comes to morality
i think of it as a as an as a natural
phenomenon as i said um which arises out
of evolutionary processes and the the
fundamental
evolutionary development is the
development of cooperation
so cooperation is really
the thing that makes life on earth and
if it exists anywhere else in the in the
universe interesting that um you can
have a bunch of organic molecules like
rna and they could just sit there in the
primordial soup forever and never do
anything but what makes things get
interesting is when molecules start
coming together to form larger molecules
and those form even larger ones that can
make copies of themselves which form
cells and so on and so forth all the way
up to
a multicellular creatures and animals
and social animals and the united
nations right um
and uh
morality as i see it is a suite of
psychological devices
that enables creatures like us to reap
the benefits of cooperation
so we have uh
into a large extent it's governed by our
emotional responses we have
feelings that make us
care about
other people
empathy or compassion um
and so we we can we can engage in a kind
of teamwork right uh that is is helpful
for survival we have emotions that make
us have have negative
react negatively to people who are not
so cooperative um we can have anger and
disgust we can be afraid of how other
people might react to us negative
feelings about our our own behavior and
we can have positive feelings about
other people's behavior so we have
positive and negative feelings that act
like carrots and sticks for ourself and
others and that's the basic
implementation of morality and it
enables teamwork it enables us to to
survive
in ways that we couldn't if we were all
just out for ourselves like sharks right
so um
all this sounds very much like what a
scientist psychologist would say
and so if i'm you know part of my job
here my role in the podcast guest is to
be the gadfly and you know push back a
little bit so
um
all that is telling me
that humans behave in a certain way and
why they behave that way from an
evolutionary biology perspective but it
doesn't quite yet tell me that they
should behave that way is that a
reasonable distinction
yes absolutely and and and i like to
start with it is
because it sets up the ought right that
what you're going to end up saying about
the aud i think depends a lot about your
broader picture of of the universe um
and so we're kind of on the same page
there i think um so when it comes to
let's let's let's let's skip meta ethics
for a second and and we'll come back and
talk about ethics right so the
fundamental moral problem
for humans in general is the basic
problem of
selfishness versus caring about others
right and that's basic morality those
emotional responses that i described and
the structures built around them solve
the problem of me versus us right
the modern moral problem is a problem of
us versus them
it's a problem of
not otherwise selfish individuals trying
to get along in a group but groups with
their own interests and their own values
trying to get along with other groups
and so if morality is the solution to
the basic moral problem of me versus you
or me versus us
we need something to solve the problem
at a higher level right and so i think
of that as a metamorality that just as
morality enables individuals to to live
together as a group and cooperate a
metamorality is something that enables
groups to live together productively in
a larger more complex and more
cooperative world so the way i think of
modern ethics is what should our
metamorality be and
uh
my view is that uh the the 19th century
utilitarians got this right i really
don't like the term utilitarian because
i think it makes you think of parking
garages and it makes you know and when
you try to explain it in terms of
maximizing happiness it makes you think
of smiley faces and things like that i
prefer to describe myself as a deep
pragmatist and i think that that flows
naturally from this conception of okay
let's start with the practical problem
of different groups with different
values and different and different
interests how do we resolve that problem
now one way to resolve that problem
would be to appeal to some universal
objective moral truth
and my view is that there probably isn't
such a thing but even if there is we
have no reliable access to it right
so instead we have to be pragmatic about
this so for practical purposes i am not
a moral
realist good right that is you know
maybe there is some abstract moral truth
that are akin to the truths of of
mathematics or or maybe there's a
theological version of it and we just
haven't figured out which of the human
versions of theological morality is is
is right or if any of them are but for
practical purposes we're left with what
we can observe
right
and so then the question is well yeah to
resolve our differences we need to make
trade-offs right well to make trade-offs
requires
having some kind of common currency if
we're going to look at you and your
groups and their values and say we want
abortion to be illegal and the other
one's like we think it should be legal
right
to
to make an all things considered
decision
about how that ought to play out means
to put all of those considerations onto
a common metric now you might say that's
unfair that's unreasonable that's not
how my people think about this but
that is what decision making requires
you either have to go one way or
or the other way and that requires some
kind of common currency
and i think that the best common
currency that we have is the common
currency of experience um and so the
fundamental insight of consequentialism
and utilitarianism more specifically
is
well it's it's really putting two things
together
one is that when you think about the
things that you care about
or that other people care about and keep
asking why do you care about that until
you run out of answers
it ultimately almost always comes down
to the quality of somebody's experience
so i say you know sean you're here at
work today why'd you go to work right
and say well i enjoy what i do but you
know i also need to pay the rent you're
like well why why why why do you need to
pay the rent why don't why don't you
just wander around you're like well you
know i'm this year i'm in boston it gets
cold outside and i said well what's
wrong with being cold well it's painful
and he said well what's wrong with pain
and then at that point you say it's just
bad
you run out of answers and so the the
thought is that when you ask those why
do you care why do you care why you care
it ultimately comes down to the quality
of somebody's conscious experience
whether it's yourself or somebody else
or a human or an animal and we don't
worry about rocks because rocks as far
as we know are not conscious and nothing
is really good or bad for them so that's
insight number one is that
con the quality of experience provides
this common currency of value but then
you say well okay but who who matters so
okay so that's what matters to you but
who really matters and utilitarianism's
insight which sounds banal now but
really was quite
you know a dramatic advance in in the in
the 18th and 19th century is everyone
matters equally and not even just humans
mattering equally but even animals so um
you know jeremy bentham the original
utilitarian you know famous famously
said we're asking the wrong question
about animals it's not a question of
whether they're as smart as us
the question is whether they can suffer
and their suffering is just as much
suffering as our suffering um
and uh
and as a result of this people like
bentham and mill were way ahead of the
curve on things like
animal rights they were early opponents
of slavery jeremy bentham even penned
one of the first
defenses of what we would now call gay
rights and he said you know i
i know that everywhere around here
people think this is the most terrible
thing in the world but when i try to
break it down in terms of the quality of
human life i just don't see why this is
so bad so
it maybe it's not and and with that
thought i in my view leapt ahead you
know two centuries in in in in moral
thinking so if you take this idea that
the quality of experience certainly
matters and is our best common currency
and the idea that everybody's experience
counts the same not that everybody has
the same experiences not that everybody
has the same culture not that everybody
values the same things but nobody is
inherently more important because
they're them right
um
then you get this idea okay well what
our metamorality the most sensible
metamorality is
try to make the world have as little
suffering as possible as most happiness
or well-being is possible taking into
account
the suffering and well-being of all
sentient beings equally and that that is
the core of it and and when you and when
you try to live that i think what you
end up being is what i call a deep
pragmatist that is you
are mostly focused on evidence on trying
to figure out what's the best way to do
this
working with human nature as it is and
not as it ought to be and aiming for
this higher ideal but very much engaged
with the practical details of the world
that's my ethics
donating money to help people can be a
wonderful and selfless act but how can
you feel confident that your donations
are improving or saving lives
effectively you could do weeks of
research to find the charities that are
out there what programs they run how
effective those programs are and how the
charity might use your money or you
could visit givewell.org
there you'll get a short vetted list of
the best charities they found at saving
or improving lives per dollar
givewell spends over 20 thousand hours
each year researching charitable
organizations and only recommends a few
of the highest impact evidence-based
charities they found over 50 000 donors
have used givewell to donate more than
750 million dollars rigorous evidence
suggests that these donations will save
tens of thousands of lives and improve
the lives of millions more and if you've
never donated to givewell's recommended
charities before you can have your
donation matched up to 250 dollars
before the end of the year or as long as
matching funds last to claim your match
go to givewell.org and pick podcast and
enter sean carroll's mindscape at
checkout make sure they know you heard
about givewell from mindscape to get
your donation matched
i wish you luck in the rebranding
program uh trying to convert
utilitarianism to deep pragmatism and i
very much am on board with
uh
both the focus on suffering and
conscious experience and the fact that
other people and other kinds of
experiences matter i do want to push
just a little bit before we get into the
empirical stuff on
utilitarianism as even the version of
consequentialism that you might need or
even that you need consequentialism i
mean uh there are some standard worries
about utilitarianism and i wonder how
you address them you know the the basic
flavor of the standard worry is it
sounds like you could destroy one
person's life if you make 100 people's
life better and i can imagine uh
completely cosmopolitan global meta
ethics that nevertheless said every
individual has some autonomy and some
rights and i cannot sacrifice the good
of that one person even if it would make
100 other people
better so is is that
does this utilitarianism emerge as the
sort of unique conclusion in your mind
from from hoping that we can find uh a
fair global meta ethics
yeah so i think that
we
it's important to look at this in
multiple levels and i think this
actually goes all the way back at least
to john stuart mill and has been a
recurring theme in other utilitarian
thinkers most notably rm hair
that is we don't want people going
around
thinking
that it's their prerogative to sacrifice
some people for the greater good of
others
why
because that would be bad because the
world would end up worse off if that was
our first level
basic disposition right
and and this is part of what i think is
the the the pragmatic element here is we
have to understand
the
the the biases and limitations
in
in in in human nature right that people
are very naturally going to say oh yeah
the greater good
that that that that's what works well
for me right what's good for america is
good for ford motor company if you're
the ceo of ford right um
uh
we're likely to be biased and we're also
likely to overestimate our ability to
predict things in our ability to control
things right so it is a very bad general
idea
to have
fallible
biased limited humans in general going
around trying to do the sort of
engineering where they're sacrificing
some people for the benefit of of of of
others that that's just a generally okay
mode of operation but now you might say
well that's kind of aren't you sort of
being a little squirrely here i mean
but but you know
you just said you had to promote the
greater good and then you just said but
we shouldn't go around thinking that
we're going to promote the greater good
but you have to ask yourself
do you think the world would actually be
better better if people thought like
that and surely you're thinking the
answer is no right well if you're
entitled to think in a sophisticated way
about the limits of human nature why
shouldn't a utilitarian right
so uh so
we want to get off the table the idea
that in general this is a
good way for people to think now
with that said
in our more reflective and sober moments
do we sometimes have to make trade-offs
suppose that there really is an enemy
threatening our nation you know this is
world war ii and and and and and and and
hitler's regime is working towards the
nuclear bomb right um
is it then acceptable to conscript some
people to fight in a war to to to to
keep hitler from taking over the world
that's sacrificing the interests of some
for the greater good right um
and and and there are
you know many
examples of things like this although
they don't usually involve such a kind
of direct sacrifice so you know in in
situations where
if you really have to choose if it
really is clear you know that if the
interests of some are not sacrificed for
the interests of of of of a larger
number
then it would be it's acceptable to to
do that but it's very dangerous to have
people going around thinking that way in
general yeah
and in practice
thinking in a more utilitarian way
is much more likely to be about giving
of yourself for the benefit of other
people than it is about sacrificing
other people for the benefit of other
people okay no i actually i mean that's
a very good point and i think that i um
appreciate something uh that i didn't
appreciate before even having talked to
you before about this stuff so so thank
you that the pragmatist aspect here
softens or at least ameliorates some of
the more
worrisome
thought experiments about utilitarianism
gone wrong uh and you're right uh about
you know
it would be contradictory to say that
utilitarianism leads to a result that is
actually making people worse off because
that's the whole point if you do it
right it's not supposed to do that but
let's let's contrast it here i think in
my book the big picture for which i
interviewed you a while ago
i drew the conventional contrast between
consequentialist ethics and
deontological ethics which are based on
rules rather than outcomes
subsequently
several people have convinced me that i
should also put virtue ethics as a third
alternative on the table there how do
you think about those two other options
well um let me start with virtue ethics
because i think it's it's clearer
uh or my answer is clearer i don't think
virtue ethics is really an answer
that is maybe you should say what it is
to the people who don't okay so so
virtue ethics sort of is
in the western tradition it's most
closely associated with aristotle but
really i think that virtue ethics is
kind of the default ethics of of of
human cultures throughout history so uh
what
the aristotelian idea is he's not giving
you a general theory that says here's
what's right and here's what's wrong and
why instead he is describing and in some
way endorsing certain kinds of moral
practices and encouraging people to
engage in them right so he'd say look
it's all about finding the right balance
you don't want to be
uh you you don't want to be a coward in
your life and unwilling to stand up to
the things that threaten you but you
don't want to be rash instead of you
know rushing into danger without you
know protecting yourself you have to
find this in you know the the the golden
mean in in in the middle and with all of
these things with all sort of matters of
of of of human life it's a matter of
balancing these competing considerations
and having of the virtues which achieve
that balance how do you achieve those
virtues well you kind of look at the
people who seem to be doing a good job
and you try to emulate them and you try
to practice you don't just get this from
theory you get this from building habits
uh and making mistakes and learning from
those mistakes and so on and i think all
of that is
right in a sense but it doesn't tell you
whether or not abortion should be
illegal
right
um it doesn't it doesn't tell you when
it's justified or not to invade a a
foreign nation it doesn't tell you how
much we should be doing to protect
future generations from from climate
change right it's just it's it's it's a
nice approach for life in a tribe
right where everybody kind of agrees on
what's right or wrong and it's a matter
of trying to live up to those standards
but in a multi-tribal world
it doesn't really tell you very much
because who's virtue is it is is it
vladimir putin's virtues as a as a
powerful strongman leader is it barack
obama's virtues as a
thoughtful progressive universalist uh
you just end up having a debate about
which virtues to implement so it's it's
a very natural and comfortable you know
there's not much to object to there
there are devastating counter examples
right to it right
but but but but that comes at the cost
of not really giving you a way to answer
the question right but that's my general
take on on on on on virtue ethics um
[Music]
when it comes to deontology this is
where i've really you know as motivated
a lot of my scientific research could go
on for it for for hours and hours here
um but i'll try to give the very short
version um
the
the idea of deontology is that there are
certain
actions that are or types of actions
that are inherently right or inherently
wrong that which must be done their
duties that much must not be done
because they're they're they're wrong or
they violate people's rights to put it
in more modern parliaments
and
my
view of deontology is that it is as a
philosophy is that it's an actually a
rationalization
of our moral emotions right um and so
you know this this comes out most
clearly in
moral dilemmas that i spent a lot of
time discussing um uh that fall under
the heading of of the trolley problem
and these days the trolley problem has
kind of become a meme where it's more of
a platform for saying well you know
would you save your high school teacher
if it meant killing five dogs or
something like you know and and and
that's to me that's not the original
interest of the trolley problem just as
a platform for for for for for
trade-offs um
the interesting thing is contrasting
different cases so if you ask people is
it okay to hit a switch to turn the
trolley away from five people and onto
one most people say that that's okay if
you ask people is it okay to push
somebody off of a footbridge so that
they land on the tracks they get killed
but it'll stop the trolley from killing
five people is that okay and most people
say no
and what we've learned from a lot of
research over the last 20 or so years is
that when people say no there it's
largely being driven by an emotional
response and it's an emotional response
that depends a lot on the physics and
mechanics of that action that because
when you push somebody off the
footbridge because it's active rather
than passive
um that is an important part because
you're harming the person as a means
it's part of your goal
as opposed to as a side effect so you're
not just turning the trolley and then it
happens that this other person is killed
as collateral damage that's important
and because it's direct um if if you
push somebody that actually feels worse
than if you hit a hit a switch that
would sort of drop them through a
trapdoor onto the tracks and
these different features combine and
make us have a negative emotional
response and there's now good evidence
that this comes from the basic
mechanisms of how we learn and in
particular reinforcement learning of the
kind that is used in uh deep
reinforcement learning in in in neural
networks and
of the kind that we see operating in
animals such as rats and monkeys and
humans and basically
what's going on there is we learn
probably in toddlerhood that it's not
okay to do things like pushing people
and so we have negative reactions
attached to those things um so that's
what's empirically what's going on in
the footbridge case now philosophically
what's going on there well a lot of
philosophers look at that and say aha
this explains exactly what's wrong with
utilitarianism
sure you could save more lives but
you're you're violating somebody's
rights when you push them off the
footbridge you're using them as a means
and so on and so forth right
well
why aren't you violating somebody's
rights when you turn the trolley away
from the five and and and on to the one
right um
i think that what's going on with
dentology and particularly in kant is
it is an attempt to put a rational gloss
on our feelings
and it's not that those feelings are bad
but those feelings are not infallible
right those feelings are
are those feelings are
uh
adapted to certain kinds of environments
and questions but don't necessarily
generalize well to other environments
and questions and this is most clear
when we look at the kinds of effects on
our feelings that are very hard to
endorse
um like it's more except morally
acceptable to trade one life for five if
you end up doing the the sacrificing of
the one by pushing that person rather
than by hitting a switch right no one
thinks that's morally important right
but our feelings think so to speak that
it's that that it's that it's morally
important and you know this isn't just
about
this isn't just about trolley cases so
someone recently asked me
about the what's going on at facebook
right and their failure to
rein in
misinformation and planning of violent
activities leading up to january 6th
and that's very much a real world thing
why why did facebook not act on that
well i would suggest and this is i
should say this is the the lot of this
really important research was done by my
colleague fiery cushman so uh i'm gonna
just credit him with with that um
if if mark zuckerberg had to sort of you
know storm the capital himself or or
stand there in front of a right-wing
group of migrant militants and hand them
uh you know guns or ties to tie up nancy
pelosi and and mike pence he wouldn't do
that i don't think whatever limitations
he may have as a moral person i don't
think he would do that right that is
active direct
pretty direct and intentional but
instead the problem that facebook faced
was
preventing harm where their role is
passive right yeah uh
and their and and and it's not very
direct and they're not trying to cause
these problems
it's a side effect of their running
their businesses as as profitably as as
as possible right um and so
these things that we've learned
so this is a case where so in the
footbridge case i think we're
overreacting
that is we have more of an emotional we
have we have more of an emotional
response because we've taken this
paradigmatically bad action pushing
somebody something you learn not to do
as a toddler right and then artificially
attaching it to the greater good right
and now it becomes an objection to
utilitarianism in the case of facebook
it's the opposite we have this
enormously consequential
action that you know is there a set of
behaviors or choices that's eroding
american democracy but it doesn't feel
like pushing somebody off of a
footbridge
because it doesn't
it doesn't have those basic
physical qualities so you asked me about
deontology i think the problem with i
think that
as a philosophy what it's essentially
doing is just trying to justify whatever
we feel
and
that's you know not bad for everyday
life if it stops people from lying and
stealing and cheating
but if we've got difficult moral
problems to solve just rationalizing our
intuitions isn't going to help because
people have different intuitions about
what's right or what's wrong and
different groups have different
interests um now look if if the
deontologist ever managed to to hit the
bull's-eye if they could if they could
deduce from self-evident first
principles what's right or what's wrong
then i would i would pack up and i would
say okay you're right you've proved it
you know um
but that hasn't happened and i don't
think that's really what it's about i
think it's about trying to tell a
rational story about feelings um and
that we're better off taking our
feelings for what they're worth
but not
but but but being able to transcend them
when necessary and i think that that's
what deep pragmatism does well this
leads beautifully into the more
empirical side of things because you've
already alluded to it but this idea that
there's sort of a
i think probably most people in their
informal morality have deontological
aspects and consequentialist aspects and
probably some virtue ethics aspects in
there but
uh you and your collaborators have been
able to say a little bit more about
literally what is going on inside the
brain when we have these uh competing
impulses so
say more about that yeah so um so take
you know our responses to cases like the
footbridge case right
um in one experiment that we did we we
gave people cases like that and we asked
people to say don't tell us what's right
or wrong here this is work done with
amitay shenhov who's now a professor at
brown um
it said you know don't tell us what's
right or wrong just tell us how bad do
you feel about this action right um
and uh
their ratings of how bad they feel about
it
correlate with activity in a part of the
brain called the amygdala
and the amygdala
is
part of a kind of
general evaluation system that is
especially active when it comes to
making a sort of rapid assessment of
something so if you you know you're
walking along and you see a snick a
stick but it sort of looks like a snake
and you kind of have that feeling where
you sort of shudder before you even
realize what you're looking at right
that is your amygdala detecting
responding to the pattern that's been
detected and saying hey pay attention to
this this could be bad right and your
amygdala plays a role in in
reinforcement learning if you are
learning to associate an electric shock
with a blue square right
when the blue square comes on your
amygdala is going to respond you know uh
before the the shock comes right so this
is part of our basic learning mechanism
here and we have good reason to think
that uh and this is again fiery
cushman's work that it's that basic
learning mechanism that's responsible
for that
emotional response some really lovely
studies done by by by fiery and uh indra
patel
um
i had people do two different kinds of
tasks so one is this task where people
are just playing a game where they kind
of make choices where they take you
essentially to different rooms and then
one room can lead to another room and
you can get to a reward and and and and
the levers that you have that take you
from room to room they have different
probabilities of taking you to different
places so one way you can end up getting
a reward
is by getting lucky that is you hit a
couple of switches that with with a low
probability get you to what you want and
if you understand the map you might say
ah there's a reward there but the more
reliable way to get there is with a
different route right right so in one
case you're using a map you're using a
model this is called model based
reasoning
in another case you just be relying on
your habits you're saying well when i
hit this lever and then hit this other
leveler i got i got the cheese i got you
know i got i got something good so i'm
going to keep doing that and you can
look at the extent to which people in
this game has nothing to do with
morality
rely on their trained habits versus rely
on their knowledge of the map
and it turns out that if you're more map
like
when you play this two this is this
multi-stage movement you know navigation
game
you are more likely to have a
utilitarian pattern
in your moral judgment um right so it
really is getting at this basic
mechanism where you know you can see
these mechanisms operating in humans
navigating mazes and in rats navigating
mazes and it's the same neurobiology
like it's a really pretty
beautifully tight connection there now
that's you know so where does the
feeling come from and where do we see it
in the brain now if i if i give you a
footbridge case and i say okay don't
tell me what's right or wrong just tell
me which action will produce better
results then you'll see more activity in
a part of the brain called the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex which is
responsible for
conscious explicit reasoning and also in
different ways cognitive control
implementing a rule or a policy and
overriding competing influences
if i say okay now i want you to make an
all things considered judgment
taking into account everything about the
footbridge case you'll see more activity
in a part of the brain called the
ventrimedial prefrontal cortex which is
the part that was famously damaged in in
phineas gage if that's a familiar uh
reference point this was the 19th
century railroad foreman who got a spike
uh through his forehead and as a result
kind of had his moral character
dramatically change even though his
ability to use language and reason was
was was was was preserved and what the
vmpfc
seems to do is serve as a hub
for
signals that bear on decision making
that that's that's that's where all of
those signals come together so you've
got the amygdala saying ah don't do that
and you've got your dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex saying well it isn't
five lives saving five lives better than
one yeah and they kind of do get out
there right um
and that's that's the basic picture of
what's going on there have been nice
studies showing how you can move these
judgments around pharmacologically
other studies showing how different
kinds of brain damage
lead to different patterns of judgment
so if you have
damage to the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex you're far more likely to say
that it's okay to push the person off of
the footbridge because the amygdala
signal can't get out into
decision making but if you have other
kinds of damage then you can have
of other effects so we can we can relate
these things you know pretty clearly to
different circuits in the brain that are
not specific to morality and that plays
similar roles in other domains for
humans and in those same other domains
for for for other mammals at least yeah
i mean there's an obvious analogy
connection or even equivalence here to
uh daniel kahneman's famous thinking
fast and slow dichotomy where you have
system one underneath the surface is
that right system one is the unconscious
underneath the surface stuff right yes
and system two is the more cognitive
rational uh deliberative part and so so
there's morality fast and slow right
that is yes and that is in fact that is
the title of one of the the the
subdivisions of my book i didn't make it
up yeah
yeah um so so i should have i should
have mentioned that as a reference point
but absolutely and and what
fiery has argued is that this
distinction between
model-free learning and decision-making
and model-based learning and
decision-making which has been really
important in computer science and
artificial intelligence and has also
been important in dissecting neural
circuits and humans and other animals
that that is really
the essence of
system one system two or as i've called
dual process uh psychology that it's
about two different ways of attaching
values to actions one by attaching
values directly to actions and the other
by attaching values to actions via an
understanding of the of the causal
connections with consequences that you
care about
a critical point in here is that this
applies not only to actions out in the
world but to mental actions right um
that that that when you when you engage
in reasoning or thought
the patterns that you follow
are patterns that have been reinforced
right you have habits of thought in the
same way that you have habits of action
and that explains
things like you know why why why we get
certain tricky math problems wrong uh
this is i'm thinking of the cognitive
reflection test if that's familiar um
uh that is we have certain patterns of
thinking reinforced that get us to to
to miss the boat
and let me let me just push back a
little bit on not even push back but
ask about how clean this distinction is
a little bit in the morality fast and
slow case because
our buddy david hume explained to us
that reasons are the slave of the
passions and
even in this more deliberative cognitive
way of being moral which you say sort of
affiliates with utilitarian impulses
uh there still is some judgment about
what is the greatest good like where
that uh i mean you can be instrumental
but you need to have a goal from
somewhere so is it more like teamwork or
is it really two alternatives
um it is
there are two different algorithms
but both algorithms involve some kind of
evaluation as you said right
so you can do things in a more model
based or a model free way a more system
order a system two way but
but there's but there but there is but
some of some evaluation as you said i
think you hit the nail on the head is
that in model based
reasoning
system two you have to be attaching some
values to the outcomes right
um and so that that is the fundamental
distinction it's not
is emotion involved or not but rather
it's are you reacting emotionally to a
particular kind of action in a
particular context or a particular
category of action
or
are you reacting to the value of the
ultimate goal or goals that are to be
you know gained or or or or or
sacrificed right and i think the the
this was appreciated early on by the
utilitarians but henry sidwiq um who's
sort of the least
popularly well-known
but the most systematic i mean
of of the three originals bentham uh
mill and sidwiq
really laid this out nicely he
distinguished between
three different levels of intuition and
what he called perceptual dogmatic and
philosophical and a perceptual intuition
is something like you see somebody do
something and you just have a sense that
it's wrong right or you imagine some
particular action you have a sense that
it's wrong
dogmatic or what you could in a less
loaded way you could call it categorical
is a reaction to a certain category of
action oh
that's a lie therefore it's wrong right
whereas if you categorize it as you know
just
strategic uh you know misdirection or
something like that then you say oh
that's not so bad right um branding
and then the philosophical intuition is
really about attaching value to
consequences so the philosophical
intuition is pain is bad suffering is
bad
happiness is good right and that is not
about a particular case it's not about a
particular action it's a judgment about
ultimate value right um and so i think
you're so i agree with what you said
that it's not that it's emotion here and
reason there
it's about
different relationships between emotion
and reason are you using your reasoning
in the service of an end that you have
ultimately on some affective basis
decided is good or bad
or
are you
or are you relying on your emotion to
sort of pass judgment on a specific
action
independent of its consequences
and that can be useful and efficient in
certain ways you know there are certain
things we don't we don't want you
thinking about whether or not all things
on balance it's better or worse if we
shoplift well the cvs really need the
money more than me right you know you in
some ways you want to have
a feelings that just say no you can't do
that that's the kind of thing we don't
do right and a utilitarian can agree
with that because the world is better
off if we have those feelings right um
but
when it comes to our ultimate values
i i i i think it makes more sense to
think about consequences okay but yeah
the the cvs example is a really good one
it it it clarifies something that you
said earlier about the pragmatic aspect
of deep pragmatism here because it's
almost like you're saying that if you're
a
super conscious utilitarian you become
deontological in some ways because the
way to get the greatest good for
everybody is if everyone acts well and
you know obey some sort of social rules
uh is there some future reconciliation
here right so the reconciliation is this
when it's life within the tribe when
it's basic everyday interactions when
most mostly at stake is my benefit or
yours do i get the money or do you do i
get the money or the cvs right
um if it's me versus us that's when you
most think fast you want to trust your
gut reactions when it's about serving
yourself versus following the rules or
or serving others
but the metamoral problem is when we
don't want to trust our gut reactions
because my tribe has its feelings about
what's right and what's wrong but so
does your tribe right and we if we all
just rely on our our feelings about
what's right or what's wrong then we we
all you know it's nuclear war it's we
all perish right so
our feelings are are pretty good
for basic morality but they're really
bad for complicated high-level
intertribal morality and and that that's
that's when we need to think slow and
that's really the
if if people ask me to nutshell my book
moral tribes that's the nutshell it for
practical purposes is that in everyday
life when it comes to basic matters of
right and wrong being a moral person
follow your intuitions and don't
overthink it right right but when it
comes to the moral issues that divide us
we need to think more and we need to to
step back from our our our moral
intuitions because it's our moral
intuitions that have us at each other's
throats in the first place i think maybe
what i'm saying is something a little
bit different because um you you i think
very plausibly
started by drawing a connection between
uh deontology and our feelings as you
put it you know our quick moral
reactions but what i'm asking in this
i'm literally just making this up right
now so i'm sure it's nonsense but what
i'm asking is given that we want to be
pragmatic utilitarians if that's what we
want to be
isn't it plausible or at least
conceivable that the way that plays out
in the real world by thinking really
really cognitively about how to make
things best for everybody
is to make up a set of rules that people
should follow even if those rules don't
map onto directly our feelings but
rather than telling everyone to do a
calculus to maximize utility just say
here are the rules for right and wrong
yeah that's right and and and
and this has actually been
[Music]
a a persistent and persistently ignored
a theme
from john stuart mill on right that you
know mill says look our our virtues have
value and we should cultivate them right
um and it's it's only at the sort of
higher levels that we need to gain be in
the explicitly utilitarian mode and it
would be unutilitarian to do otherwise
because things go worse when we
ignore the basic everyday rules right
but then there are times when those
rules maybe need to be reconsidered so
you can have everyday
rules about
gender roles right where you know the
everyday rules if you've watched uh you
know if you've seen uh you know fiddler
on the roof and you know tradition and
who does this and who does that right um
and you know you don't have to you don't
need a musical to tell you about uh you
know right that that that those are
aspects of everyday life that maybe we
want to question and reconsider right so
you know it's uh
and and there are other domains as well
you know what we choose to eat for
for food for example is something where
if we just rely on our intuitions of
course it's fine to you know eat a
hamburger even if uh it's coming from
you know meat from animals that were
were
tortured on their way to production
right and that are uh you know
worsening our climate crisis you know we
we need to be willing to rethink some
everyday things
as well
yeah this is extremely helpful you're
reinvigorating my youthful enthusiasm
for utilitarianism that i was
backsliding from for a little while but
uh and it also leads directly into what
i wanted to talk about next and again
which you've already alluded to which is
that
uh the sort of switch of moral thinking
when we start thinking about these
global problems these inter-tribal
problems um
maybe the place to start is with the
tragedy of the commons because i know
that you've talked about that a lot and
how that plays into our moral uh ways of
thinking um yeah so this comes back to
something earlier that is you know the
tragedy of the commons uh is the the
story comes from uh garrett hardin who
you know in the late 60s was worried
about overpopulation and he gave the
analogy of you know herders with too
many animals on their fields and then
there all the grass is gone and all the
animals end up dying right and we need
to restrict the size of our our of our
herds or else everybody's animals are
going to die and he was imagining that
humans that you know we're going to
overpopulate uh and and destroy their
their resources but it's a nice metaphor
for the general
me versus us problem right um
and uh
as i said you know we we have
our
our behavior on the commons is governed
by basic feelings right that is if i
care about my fellow herders then i'm
not going to you know sneak in some
extra sheep and and and take more of the
grass right um and i'll be angry at
other herders if they do that and i'll
be grateful to other herders who you
know uh restrict their their herd for
the common good um
and i'll feel bad about myself if i even
contemplate doing this right so we have
these positive and negative feelings
that we apply to ourselves and and to
others that get us to be able to live
sustainably on the commons now we face
these global
commons problems related to things like
you know uh
climate change right
and
it's complicated because it's not just a
bunch of individuals with personal
feelings for each other instead it's
it's groups with
norms and philosophies and with
hierarchies and with some individuals in
the hierarchy maybe they can benefit
from by saying to hell with the planet
because if you're
make your livelihood
selling uh
you know products that produce a lot of
carbon
you might just say you know i can i can
i can move to wherever if things get a
little too hot where i am but i sure am
raking it in now uh you know
selling uh petroleum products right so
and then those people can try to
influence people and make them think
that it's a terrible violation of your
freedom and your dignity and your
autonomy if you're asked to make
any kind of sacrifices uh for the for
the sake of the planet or even to to to
vote for legislation that would rain
some of these things in at you know not
at the level of consumers but uh at the
level of you know efficiency standards
for cars and and investing in green
energy and stuff like that so
the basic feelings that we have as as as
sort of
herders on the common pasture in
everyday life so to speak
they get they they don't transfer up to
the larger problem and and and that's
where we need
to understand the problem and uh and and
and make choices that are going to
produce good consequences instead of
good feelings right i think the way that
you put it which which was very vivid
and helpful was that you know we climbed
the evolutionary ladder and then we kick
it away right yeah yeah and that start
from some point that is ingrained into
us in a very basic way and we can sort
of
take in our values from that process
without necessarily giving into the
first impulses that that process leave
us leaves us with that's right yeah and
and um
well well said i'll leave it at that
well
i'm quoting you but but what it means is
well so i guess i should be asking you
what does it mean when push comes to
shove you did this you have this nice
data from experiments where you've asked
people to play the public goods game
right and
they're asked to sort of give money away
um
i was surprised both by the average
result and by the differences in results
under time pressure and not
yeah so in that original study this was
work done with dave rand and martin
novak um
we found that putting people under time
pressure made them more likely to do the
usaish thing to sort of to contribute to
a public good rather than doing the the
the selfish thing um
it turns out it's it's complicated
there's been a lot of research on this
using a lot of different methods and uh
you know it seems the the short and long
of it from my understanding i haven't
followed the whole sort of almost decade
of literature that's followed this is
that it really depends a lot on your
cultural experience right so um if your
dominant
response is is to be cooperative because
you've lived in a world that rewards
cooperativeness with strangers right not
just with with with your with your
friends and family then that's going to
be your dominant response but if you've
lived in a world in which you really
can't trust strangers very much uh
and and where
where your
your response when you're put in this
weird situation of cooperating with a
bunch of people you don't know in this
sort of sterilized anonymous context
then then then it can even go the
opposite way and i think this was nicely
sort of uh
foreshadowed by an amazing study done by
benedict hermann um that was published
back in 2008 where he had people do
public goods games in different cities
around the world okay and in
very sort of cosmopolitan places like
denmark and switzerland and boston
you you saw people
cooperating right out of the gate and
when they were given the opportunity to
to punish people who didn't cooperate
uh or to punish other people but and i
say punish i mean like you pay a dollar
to take three dollars away from somebody
else um not corporal punishment they're
not whipping each other yeah uh
cooperation you know was sustained and
in other places cooperation kind of
started out in the middle and then the
cooperators punished the non-cooperators
and uh
and cooperation went up but then in
other places
where the the social world tends to be
smaller so this would be places like
athens at least at the time or or or or
oman
or riyadh
people who didn't cooperate punished to
the cooperators
and there was a kind is known as
anti-social punishment and it was a kind
of resentment of coercion right that it
was look i don't know you i don't know
who you are i don't like this whole game
where we're suppose i'm supposed to put
my money on the line and trust you and
and i don't like the way that you're
trying to make me do this right and so i
think that what that reflects is a kind
of smaller world so we have
uh social heuristics we have
emotional tendencies that we've learned
about when it's safe to trust people and
when it's not and when we should resist
social structures that try to get us to
trust more than we should right
um
and uh
and so i i
then of course the question is well
if we have people who are more globally
trusting
and people who aren't all trying to
live in a world that requires some kind
of global cooperation
how do we fix that right
and
and and i don't think
that the answer is just to say hey
riyadh athens be more trusting right the
trust trust has to be earned right
and so what we really need to do
is build the kind of structures social
structures
that make
trust and global cooperation feel like
the natural
thing to do and this is what a lot of
what i'm working on and and thinking
about these days yeah i mean this is
this is a huge set of issues that i do
want to get into but there's one thing i
don't want to uh i want to go back very
quickly because
in the public goods game
where i mean very roughly you're just
giving people the opportunity to share
their money a little bit it's not a very
complicated game um and there's this
result that when you ask them to hurry
they're more
generous when you ask them to think
about it they're like i'm going to keep
the money now
that seems to be a little bit in tension
with the idea that we're going to become
a more successful global inter-tribal
society by engaging our rational
thinking faculties rather than just
acting in the moment how do you
reconcile those two things so so the
public goods game is a me versus us
problem right it's a basic problem of
the tribe and that is
exactly when i think you know we need to
be at least
more often relying on our gut reactions
right we need to be filled with a sense
of trust and generosity towards the
people
who we interact with in daily life
assuming that they will
do r reply in in in kind right yeah
when it comes to national and global
politics and the things that divide us
that's where we can't rely on our
intuitions because it's
it's it's us versus them so i think the
intuitive success
in the prisoner's dilemma and the public
goods game illustrates the first part of
the overall larger equation so to speak
in moral tribes which is
when it's me versus us think fast you
know
cultivate those pro-social intuitions
right but when it's us versus them got
it where it's different versions of
pro-sociality
competing against each other that's
that's when we have to step back and
and think in a more recent kind of way
and where
i mean maybe you can say a little bit
about the origin of this
uh
conceptualization of the world in terms
of us versus them i mean this is a
strong
legacy of our evolutionary history right
that there's a group that we're a member
of and we fight for the group this is
like one of our deepest impulses as far
as i can tell yeah yeah i mean and this
we share this with our with our primate
ancestors i mean if you look at
chimpanzees uh
you know they'll patrol their border and
if they're if if a group of of chimps on
patrol find a chimp from another group a
male chimp from another group that is uh
you know
defenseless they'll just kill that ship
right um i and and and with humans it
seems to be a very basic uh response uh
catherine kinsler did some really nice
research where she showed that very
young infants
recognize a a native versus an
unfamiliar accent of someone who's even
speaking a language that they understand
and they're more likely to accept a gift
from someone who speaks say english in
in their native english accent versus
someone who speaks english with a french
accent right and you can go the other
way it's not just english
french or other other other languages of
course um that we you know
come into the world it seems
ready to divide the world into
us and and and and them
but
there's some flexibility there that we
don't you know we we
we don't just detect who shares our
genes uh or something like that and only
trust those people who are ingrouped in
that way
we rely on
cultural markers to tell us okay you're
a christian i can trust you or you speak
my language so i i i can trust you
and because cultural flexibility
there's no reason in principle why we
all can't belong to the same tribe right
there are always going to be forces
pushing against that
because someone can say you know
rather than being third in command for
the big tribe i would be better off
being king of a smaller tribe right and
so so so the the the the possibility of
of of human hierarchy
is
is
always creating
incentives to defect at the cultural
level and i think that that's really
what's going on with ethnic nationalism
in the united states and and other
countries is that the world has been
moving towards
more and more global values right
but there are there are winners and
losers in that process right
and someone like like like like trump or
le pen in in in in in france or uh you
know nigel farage in in in in england
and so on and so forth they're saying no
america first
france is for the french you know don't
don't do we don't we don't we don't want
to be part of this
just us just those of us who really you
know got that usy feeling right um
and they play to that and then they say
and those other people they're coming to
kill you and rape you
rape you or your or your sisters and
daughters right and they they they and
they're and they're stealing your jobs
right those people in china are stealing
your jobs and
they and and why would they do that well
it's hard to be king of the world but
but maybe you could be president
if you push those buttons
hard enough right and uh and and and so
the great challenge is to
we have this open-ended flexibility to
see us as very small
or very large
and i think the challenge we're facing
right now
geopolitically
is
between
forming a truly
larger us
uh
and uh
um
or
or breaking off into our smaller more
comfortable uses
well it's a challenge in part i just
read a there was a column the new york
times by thomas edsel very recently uh
quoting some academic paper that claimed
that
one of the reasons why authoritarianism
can be so attractive is just because it
gives meaning to people's lives right it
gives them a purpose and in a world
where
the world is so big you don't meet
everybody uh and it can seem like there
are invisible forces keeping you down
then
it is it is a very attractive position
to just circle the wagons a little bit
right yeah absolutely um
and i think that's especially true
if people feel like they're they're
sliding you know that there's been this
big debate in the social sciences is the
rise of trump and ethnic nationalism is
it about economics or is it about
tribalism is it about hierarchy and us
versus them
and i i think it has to be both i mean
the data point more strongly towards
tribalism and us versus them because
individual variation in economic
situation is not a very good predictor
of you know it's not about my pocketbook
and people don't attribute their you
know personal gain or loss of income to
what's going on you know
geopolitically
but you know over the
last 40 years
inequality in places like the united
states has gone up and up and up and the
prospects of someone who doesn't have a
college degree have have have slowly
slid down and that is that is trump's
base it's it's
and and it's it's made
people without college degrees um
and
and that sense of being left behind i
think it doesn't require
you to go down that nationalist route
you can go a more burny kind of
direction and try to you know
push for a more
egalitarian social structure
but
for many people the most comfortable and
appealing route is to say enough of this
uh
i want a country that's just for
people like me
who look and sound like me
and and then that can really be
reinforced
by these uh you know wolf stories uh uh
uh uh about the
the the the outsiders who are coming to
take your jobs and physically harm you
and uh and and and then those uh
you know elites who are in cahoots with
them um and and who are just you know
profiting off of your your demise and
then those those stories really
reinforce that sense of victimization
and
uh
and it makes that yeah let's just be us
feeling very powerful well it goes back
in my mind to
one of the things you said about
utilitarianism right from the start um
we
very naturally our intuitions what we
grow up thinking in terms of morality
and correct behavior
give a lot more weight to people close
to us and like us than to people far
away and actually one of the reasons why
one of my worries about utilitarianism
is it
has this unrealistic bent sometimes
where it says you know every person's
experience counts precisely equally and
even if that's true in a sort of god's
eye view sense it's almost impossible to
imagine real human beings acting that
way right right
well so this is the pragmatist part
coming back again right is that if
you're a good utilitarian you start with
humans as they are and not demand that
they live up to some impossible ideal so
my view is
we've made a lot of progress towards
that right people care a lot more about
people on the other side of the world
than they ever used to right um
and
and people you know people's moral
circles are much wider than they used to
be and the idea of you know at least in
in in in the west you know not eating
meat which is delicious uh because you
just care about animal suffering that
would just be absurd so many of the
things that we we consider perfectly
normal and reasonable now would have
just seemed as absurdly idealistic for
most of human history
but you're absolutely right that you
know there's no prospect anytime soon of
people caring more about strangers than
they care about their own friends and
family and you know maybe in the end you
know we don't we don't need to go that
far in order to have a well-functioning
global society we just need to not burn
ourselves up uh you know with
with with with with carbon in the
atmosphere or nuclear weapons or that or
or a supercharged pandemic right um
so you know the way i see it is
you don't have to give up on loving your
children just you know give up
ten percent of your income or one
percent of your income uh and and devote
it to good causes and support
political movements that are more
egalitarian rather than less less
egalitarian and that uh promote global
cooperation rather than than undermining
it um
my friend charlie bresler who runs the
uh an organization called you can save
which was started by peter singer
um
ultimately about alleviating global
poverty is he has a great phrase that he
brings into this which is personal best
that is
don't it's not helpful to think of this
in terms of trying to be
perfect in terms of of
valuing all lives perfectly equally you
know of caring about strangers no more
than or as much as you care about
yourself or your friends and family
instead just ask yourself
can i be a little less selfish can i be
a little less tribalistic yeah right
um and if and if that becomes easy then
you you dial it up right and so you know
it's with anything else whether you're
you're on a diet or you're trying to get
in shape or learning to meditate or
whatever it is you don't start off by by
by saying okay i'm going to you know be
an olympic athlete tomorrow or be very
disappointed if i'm not instead you say
okay can i can i can i can i run one
mile right without stopping right and
then once that becomes easy you build up
and so i think you know
aristotle got one thing right is that
these things don't just happen because
we've heard some theory
you need practice you need to build up
right and um and i think as individuals
and as cultures we can scaffold and we
can build up and make ourselves more
globally
pro-social without you know breaking the
moral bank so to speak
let me just throw out a thought that i
have no idea whether it's relevant here
but i recently did a podcast with
christopher mims who is a journalist of
wall street journal about
industrial ecology and how stuff gets to
us in the modern world right how
the fun anecdote is if you're if you
catch a fish off the coast of scotland
and you eat it as a you know from the
supermarket in scotland chances are
after being caught it was sent to china
to be filed and then sent back because
it's just so much easier and cheaper to
do that than to fillet in scotland and
so my point is that
even though our sort of circles of
caring have grown as we become a more
interconnected world we're also so
differentiated in what we do
that the things that are right next to
us or the the ways of living that are
right next to us can become a little bit
invisible right we're not i'm not aware
until talking with chris and reading the
book uh about the truck drivers who are
bringing me this stuff or i could go my
life um
not really
connecting in some deep way to the
people who serve me food which maybe 200
years ago would have not been impossible
is this a is this a new challenge for
global morality that were that were so
complex and interconnected but also
differentiated
yeah i think
i think that yeah as as technology has
become more complicated and the economy
has become more complicated
the
the effects of our choices as agents
within the global economy
are much more opaque right
and sometimes it's just interesting you
know to think of you know how many
different nations participated in you
know
making it possible for me to have the
iphone in my pocket or something like
that and sometimes it
it it really matters right i mean again
to come back to a familiar example
um
i think very few people
would eat factory farm meat if they
spent much time in a factory farm right
but we're just separated from it and
that's why the the the the companies
that do factory farming
work very very very very hard to keep
footage of what's going on in there
out right um but you know to us it just
just tastes like a chicken sandwich um
uh and uh
and of course that's one example but you
know
labor practices and
uh
you know reinforcing certain kind of
corporate structures you know i mean i
you know every ev every time you buy
something from amazon you know you're
you're you're reinforcing a kind of
economic structure and i still buy
things from amazon but i have you know i
have concerns about that i feel bad
about it sometimes i just want my big
box of toilet paper and i don't want to
have to you know
organize my life around this right um so
yes i i agree that the world is so
complicated that you know it's
it's it's it's almost it's impossible
for us to sort of keep track of all the
pieces and yet
we can't just we'd be a terrible mistake
to just throw up our hands and say oh
it's inscrutable so i'm just gonna do
what i feel like right so we have to
find a kind of find some middle
middle ground where we you know we we we
pick our battles and we we learn what we
need to learn
most
and and and make good enough choices
well on the more optimistic side you do
i forget whether it was your research or
you were quoting somebody else but you
do have research where when you make
people who are nominally in different
tribes work together on some task and
cooperate they become much more friendly
and trusting of each other is that an
overgeneralization or is that okay um
yeah this is actually work that's that's
ongoing um i mean first of all this is
an old idea uh going back to
gordon alport uh in in his book the
nature of prejudice where he emphasized
that
contact between groups he was mostly
focused on race um
in a cooperative context
can really you know
bring people together and you know he he
gives he gave the example of something
that was very salient at the time was
the integration of the u.s military and
you know let me say there are a lot of
things wrong historically and today with
with the us military and other
militaries and
the integration of the us military
didn't just happen for noble reasons uh
that you know the united states many
people were happy to have black people
risking their lives for the united
states instead of themselves or their
their their children but whatever
complex and questionable motives might
have been behind
creating a more integrated military
it did create a more integrated military
and a more
integrated culture
i now am doing research on this with a
brilliant student named evan d philippis
who's uh in
you know in the organizational behavior
program at harvard business school and
and in the psychology department and we
have uh
republicans and democrats working
together as partners in an online quiz
game that we've created and i can't say
anything about the results here other
than it'll say that i'm very excited
about this research um okay good i think
that the the principles behind it could
really be
helpful well good i mean maybe that's uh
the right segway into wrapping up with
more um
uh programmatic pointers for ourselves
and our listeners because you know you
actually as far as i can tell
taken these thoughts about being a good
person and global metamorality etc and
thought about how to
make them uh make a difference in our
choices in our everyday lives and our
giving to charities and things like that
yeah so yeah since since publishing
moral tribes and doing a lot of this
work
on
you know very abstract and theoretical
issues
i kind of i wanted as a moral
psychologist and you know
student of social behavior to work on
things to sort of apply my philosophy
rather than than defend it and
understand the mechanics behind it
although i'm interested in that as well
and
one of the things that's been most
important to me personally and and
philosophically is
uh you know
living utilitarianism living deep
pragmatism using what doing what you can
to do as much good as possible and the
most straightforward way that
individuals who are lucky enough to have
some
resources
the most straightforward way that people
can do good is by
supporting charities that are highly
effective
so most people don't know this but the
most effective
charities are you know orders of
magnitude more effective than typical
charities so to give an example that
comes from uh toby org uh
you know to to you could help a blind
person in the united states uh by paying
for the training of a guide dog and that
costs about fifty thousand dollars and
that's a really wonderful valuable thing
to do if you can spend fifty thousand
dollars on a on a car for yourself for
an addition to your house or something
like that
you do much more good by by helping a
blind person get around in the world
right
but
you can
fund in in other nations a surgery to
prevent a infection from trichoma
can be done for about a hundred dollars
you can prevent somebody from going
blind for about a hundred dollars so
we're talking about you know something
like a thousand-fold difference in
effectiveness um and it's not to say
that the person in the united states
who's blind that it's not important that
we shouldn't help them but if you have
to choose between helping a thousand
people not go blind or one person manage
their blindness to me there's no
question about what we should do right
um and there are many things that are as
effective as trachoma surgery so things
like distributing insecticidal malaria
nets that for very low cost can prevent
people from dying of malaria or
deworming treatments where a simple pill
can prevent uh can can destroy parasitic
infections that are really debilitating
and prevent children from going to
school and getting an education and
those deworming treatments can cost less
than a dollar right and make a huge
difference in someone's life so the
charities that support these things are
enormously impactful like it's kind of
mind-blowing how much good they can do
for so little money right and so then
and i've tried do you know do you know
by the way uh do you know by the way
givewell
yes so actually so i'll give you i just
want to mention very very quickly
givewell is a sponsor of the mindscape
podcast oh great i think i suspect i'm
recording this week's ahead of time of
course but i have i have a high
probability that i will be giving an ad
for givewell during i've already given
it by now so i'm glad to run
so so givewell was the the organization
that really pioneered doing this
effectiveness research and the and the
thing i'm about to talk about giving
multiplier is is making use of their
their their their research um
so what do you do so i've i've
wanted to study i've been studying the
psychology of this for a while how do
you get people to
give more and how do you get people to
give more effectively and i initially
tried
trying to convince people you know as a
site experimenting with convincing
people the way i was convinced which is
with philosophical arguments of the kind
that peter singer gave right which is
you know there's a child who's drowning
in the pond and you could save that
child but you're gonna muddy up your
clothes it'll cost you some money but
you save someone's life is it worth
doing that of course and so i you know
present people with this and say so now
are you willing to commit to supporting
the most effective charities and they're
like nah
you know or a very small number of
people you know will go that direction
but most people not so much um and
and then with uh lucius caviola who's
been a postdoc in my lab we hit on a
fundamentally different strategy which
takes a much more deep pragmatist
approach in retrospect which is instead
of saying
don't you know
use your money on yourself or on the
charities that you love that really
speak to your heart you know don't do
this instead do this other thing
supporting deworming treatments in
africa and asia where you have no
personal connection to this we just said
what if you do both and so we started
doing these experiments where we just
said hey
you have a certain amount of money um
you could give it all to this charity
that you chose or all to this charity
that experts recommend or you can do a
50 50 split and we found that people
love the idea of doing a 50 50 split um
and uh and that more money ends up going
to the highly effective charity if you
give people the 50 50 split option than
if you don't right even though only half
of the money is going to that charity
and so we did some other experiments
where we looked at you know try to
understand why this is the case and it
seems like it's a kind of heart head
balance that people want to give
something to the charity that they love
but then once they've given something
they also really like the idea of being
highly effective and competent and and
and you know using the scientific
research to do as much good as possible
and we found that people really like
this if we say hey if you make a 50 50
split charity where you pick one and we
pick one or you pick one of ours
and we'll add
25 on top to both donations people go oh
wow that's great right um
and uh
and uh and we found not only that we
asked people said hey would you be
willing to take some of what you gave
and uh
and and then uh use it you know you can
use it to to pay matching funds for
somebody else right a lot of people were
willing to do that not everybody but but
but a lot and when we did that
when people put a dollar sort of into
matching it ends up moving more than a
dollar towards highly effective
charities so we said my gosh well we
should try this in the real world so
we created this website and i say we i
mean lucious caviolo my collaborator and
his awesome web design friends um
i
created this website called giving
multiplier
which works just like the way i
described so if you go to
givingmultiplier.org
you'll see
an option first to
pick any
charity that you like any registered uh
charity in the united states and you
enter that in and then it says okay so
if that's your charity that you chose
your personal favorite and then we have
a list of currently nine charities that
cover a lot of different things so some
of it is global health and poverty so
fighting malaria deworming treatments
vaccines
trachoma surgeries and things like that
some things are we have a climate change
charity that seems to be extremely
effective we also have a charity called
give directly which just
gives money to people um in in in poor
nations and research shows that they do
an excellent job of using that money to
build businesses and you know
take care of basic necessities and that
it and
that it ends up helping the whole
community um so this is kind of a little
bit some people like this because it's
like you might see it as less
paternalistic that you're not you know
saying here have a malaria net even if
that's not what you would ask for
instead it's just saying here are some
resources and i trust you to do as much
good for yourself as you can with it so
we have a lot of different things but
all of these things
have either been
rigorously tested with experiments
shown to be highly effective
or they're more long-term things like
preventing the next pandemic where it's
reasonable to assume that a relatively
modest investment in research can have a
huge
impact um so you pick your charity you
pick one of these charities that experts
recommend and then you say okay how much
do i want to give total um and then we
have this little slider um where you can
decide how much you want to allocate to
your personal favorite charity versus
the charity from our list and you know
the only constraint there is you have to
give at least 10 percent to one of the
charities that we recommended and then
giving multiplier adds a match
to your donation
um uh
and i i think right now it's
if you it's it's a 50 match if you give
everything if you just make a donation
to the highly effective charity the one
that you chose and we do a 25 match so
uh
for um
if you split 50 50 and you can do things
in in in between
um and this has been great so far we
launched this less than a year ago and
it's it's raised over half a million
dollars most of that going to
the world's most effective uh charities
uh
and uh we have created a special code
that unlocks a higher matching rate for
your listeners so if you put in the code
mindscape all caps all one word then you
get a higher matching rate than you
otherwise would um so we encourage
people to to give this a try and the
idea here is that
you know
you don't have to be a perfect
utilitarian
it's okay to care about and and
i do this myself my wife and i we give
to our local schools and the greater
boston food bank and things like that
that we we don't give up on having these
more personal connections so you support
something that's personally meaningful
to you but you also give something to
something that's
the research says is is is super
effective and then we help out and and
we also have a system where
if you donate you have the option to
donate
part of your donation
to the matching fund so you can pay it
forward for somebody else and a lot of
our donors do this um and and the whole
cycle has just been self-sustaining so
it's been this wonderful sort of
virtuous circle of effective giving
where people support things they
personally care about but also
go with the research and it's just been
running on its own and so we're excited
for our second
holiday season coming up and you know
hopefully we're going to get over a
million dollars and and
and then some and um so i hope i hope
your listeners will
we'll we'll find this some will find it
useful and and gratifying yeah no i mean
it's a great pitch and i i i'm a big
believer in both the head and the heart
so i think that's a very good way of
saying it you know i'm always going to
give some money to the local pet shelter
where we got our rescue kittens even
though i know that it's not quite as
impactful on the world as uh giving
money to to help disease or poverty
elsewhere in the world but i also try to
do that and you know likewise you and i
both like it when rich people give money
to our universities to help us do
research and support students and things
like that also probably not the most
impactful but i think that the idea that
you do a little bit of both and
everything gets better is a very clever
one yeah yeah so
yeah thanks um excited about this and uh
looking forward and it works whether or
not you're a utilitarian which is which
is the best thing about it because you
know yeah our opinions change about that
so it's this is uh
view this as a way to
expand the circle of of of effective
giving and and um
you know
create a way for people to
do a lot more good than they otherwise
would
while still
feeling connected to what they're what
they're doing and feeling connected to
the other people who are part of this
that um that
when you support the matching fund you
you participate in this in this cycle um
good luck for the listeners to think
about feel and do also so joshua green
thanks so much for being on the blind
skate podcast thanks so much for having
me this has been great
[Music]
you